99.99
of the volume of the atom is just empty
space so when i slam my hand down on my
desk the reason it comes to a stop is
not because solid matter has hit solid
matter it's because the electrons in the
atoms on the surface of my hand are
feeling the electric repulsion negative
charge of the electrons in the atoms in
the surface of the desk and it's
electromagnetic repulsion that is giving
matter this sense of solidity that's why
you can't walk through brick walls
what was keats's problem with newton
uh he didn't i mean i guess he didn't
like science he didn't like that newton
had destroyed the beauty of the rainbow
he said
you've reduced it to its prismatic
colors
you know newton's work on you know the
prism and all the different colors of
the rainbow so as far as keeps was
concerned the rainbow was beautiful in
and of itself
but if you try and explain it
scientifically somehow that makes it
cold and rational or hard and no longer
beautiful and of course keeps was wrong
is there not an element of that the
mystery
and suspense
and a lack of understanding about
something that sort of adds a bit of
magic or do you think that understanding
it
enhances it even more well no i know i
agree i mean absolutely it's it's you
know the anticipating what you've got
for christmas as a kid you know and the
presents have yet to be unwrapped once
you've unwrapped them yeah you know
you're happy you've got what you wanted
but it's sort of
from then on it's sort of downhill right
so so yeah the mystery the anticipation
is
you know part part of the the pleasures
of of life but you get that in science
as well you know even in science the the
the excitement the the uh
the pleasure that we derive in doing
scientific research is the journey it's
the it's the trying to solve the mystery
once we've solved the mystery once we've
discovered you know the higgs boson or
gravitational waves yeah okay tick that
box move on to something else so i think
it applies in science as well as not
inside science isn't about reducing
everything to cold hard facts and then
you know that's it the hard rationalism
is no longer no i mean science can be
spiritual science can be uplifting and
wondrous as well
i noticed that
you've sort of hinted there at a
scientific version of hedonic adaptation
where you are chasing after the higgs
boson and you're chasing after it and
chasing after it and you build this big
thing and it's underneath switzerland
and somewhere else and then you find it
and then you go right okay we've done
that
now what are we going to discover next
scientific adaptation
it is a bit like that i mean i should
say of course those scientists and
engineers who built the large hadron
collider and and and spent decades you
know designing and preparing for this
experiment and finally you know getting
the data
of course they wanted to find the higgs
boson otherwise you know they're you
know
what you've spent how many billions of
dollars building this thing and so they
want but for the rest of us it would
have been more exciting had they not
discovered it because that would have
meant there's new stuff to discover
our current theory is is is
missing something back to the drawing
boards potential nobel prizes we don't
want
we try to find the answers we try to
seek the truth
but we sort of don't want it to come to
an end is dark matter and dark energy at
the moment a a big
um element of that that we have this
stuff that kind of theoretically needs
to be there and yet
no one can find any evidence for it
yeah well i mean it's probably not fair
to say we don't have evidence for it we
have evidence so we know it's there we
just don't
understand its origin what it's made of
and so on
um there's there was a um an article
written by stephen hawking about 40
years ago where he said you know is the
end in sight for theoretical physics so
he was suggesting that you just need to
dotsomize cross some t's and we'll have
a theory of everything explaining all
physical phenomena in the universe
at the time they were just starting to
think about super string theory this new
mathematically powerful theory that
describes all the the forces of nature
and they thought they were nearly there
and of course it turns out wow not that
string theory is wrong
but there's there's plenty more we have
yet to understand we're further away
from a theory of everything than we
thought dark matter we know is there we
we can see its gravitational pull it's
in i mean a better name for the before
it would have been invisible matter or
transparent matter we know it's there
because it has a gravitational pull like
all types of matter it it can attract
things towards it it holds galaxies
together and so on you just don't know
what it's made of and that's frustrating
it's a fun kind of frustration but it's
a frustration nevertheless dark energy
is similarly it's something that's
making the universe making space expand
ever more quickly
so we know that's happening because you
can see distant galaxies moving away
faster and faster and faster but we
don't know what it is that's causing
that anti-gravity push of everything
away from from everything else so we're
a long way from
having all the answers and that's good
that keeps us in work am i right in
saying that the ratio of dark matter to
physical matter is actually in the
it's swayed toward dark matter as well
yeah i think instead of something like
five to one or something like that i
think yeah there's there's much more
dark matter
than invisible myself you can't interact
with it's so wild i read um
the five stages of the universe which
is the really really interesting book
and they said that um during the big
bang there were almost exactly equal
parts of mata and antimatter i think it
was
um one million to one million and one
in the particles but the one
was mata rather than antimatter and that
one out of every one million versus one
million and one ratio yeah is that's all
the matter
that's left in the universe dude that
blew my mind because everything else
cancels out exactly but you think okay
so how much more matter could there have
been well a million times more
yeah well you can start you could
probably work out how much more matters
because that matter and antimatter
annihilated to form energy
uh and and so we can measure the the how
much energy there is in in the in the
universe as well but the the real puzzle
is why was it a million and one
versus a million why weren't they
exactly balanced equal and opposite that
asymmetry but the imbalance between them
that's another big outstanding puzzle in
physics what's your thoughts about the
fine-tuned universe you've mentioned
there about dark energy and i think is
that the cosmological constant is that
what dark energy causes
yes that's that's
the the consensus is growing that that's
what dark energy is okay and that is
so
fine
the the the amount of of push that that
causes for galaxies to move apart ever
so slightly and i think the fine tune
universe theory is that you have all of
these different constants and the strong
and weak
forces and
any one of them
a knife edge either way would completely
ruin the rest of them and wouldn't
permit mata to exist the way it does
what's your what's your thoughts about
the fine-tuned universe well i i mean
obviously we there could be an
underlying reason why
these
physical quantities have the values that
they do i mean it's thank goodness they
do or we wouldn't be here talking about
it um
the
the lazy explanation but is still sort
of
appealing for most people is that our
universe isn't unique that
our universe is just a bubble within a
higher dimensional multiverse in which
every possible universe exists and so
there'll be lots of other universes in
which the constants of physics have
different values and those universes
won't have evolved to develop galaxies
and stars and planets and and
life in in at least one place
um and so we are the lottery ticket
winners you know it's not fine-tuned
just that one universe had to have the
right combination of constants to give
rise to the structure that we see so
it's not surprising you know there's a
lot to be taken how it's so unlikely you
know that i've won the ticket well
somebody had to win it and it's you you
know it's us
is that the
is that called the observation selection
effect
i think that's the reason i think i
think yes i think it's it's it's people
talk about it as being the anthropic
principle but yes the observation
selection i think i've i've vaguely
heard of that i think that that's i
think that's right because the the point
is um the only universe in which
you could consider the fact that you
were lucky to have been in a fine-tuned
universe is the one that was fine-tuned
for you anyway so you kind of it's kind
of like begging the question a little
bit i suppose it's it's a circular
argument how you know yes how else how
could it have been anything else
otherwise we wouldn't be here to to talk
about it yes precisely so it seems to me
that science has gotten a bit of a bad
rap over the last few years there's
pretty much no subject area where
scientists and researchers aren't
treated with um
aggressive skepticism if not
outright contempt
at least by some areas of the general
public have you noticed this trend
recently as well
i think there's always been anti-science
sentiments from people either who are
suspicious of it for whatever
ideological reason you know or cultural
reason or religious reason
um and then there's
you know
people who you know you you have your
own
biases and your own world view and you
don't like anything that goes against
that and of course this this
as humans we've always had this problem
this issue
but of course been amplified by the
internet and social media and so that
that's democratized the voices of
everyone on the planet
and therefore you know we are
hearing every possible
argument for or against i don't know
whether there are more people who are
anti-science now i just think they tend
to shout more loudly
and and they do have a voice now whereas
in the past maybe they didn't so we tend
to think things are worse than they
probably are yeah isn't that interesting
that um
no one would
no one would criticize the fact that
everyone's
uh egalitarian ability to talk online to
communicate their ideas you know
universal good pretty much everybody
would would probably say that but the
problem is
um in the past the only people that were
able to get a platform to be able to
reach a million people instantly were
those that had
very slowly over time proven their worth
of being somebody that could reach a
million people whereas now you know you
take the right video of your cat
and yeah there you go there's a million
views
yeah i mean
there's good and bad about social media
and and and youtube and so on you know
say it's democratized our voices so so
we're not just fed the information from
the the the powerful or those with
vested interests
um
also i mean i i love twitter you know
because
i follow the right organizations and
people that are going to give me the
news that that i'm going to find
interesting
but yeah it has meant that everyone has
a say now the the the difficulty that
many people have is how do you
discriminate from those who've earned
their stripes who know what they're
talking about who have the expertise
because they've spent years studying
thinking
reflecting on
what they what they're telling you and
those who
it's just mere opinion and sort of ideal
ideology um
it's difficult for the average person to
have to dig in and investigate where is
this information coming from is this
from a trustworthy source what is this
is this evidence valid uh
and so
it's still something we're struggling
with as a society how how to cope with
so much information coming at us all the
time yeah well increasingly the value
or the the smartest people are the ones
that are the most discriminating now you
know
you have to be
because there is way more noise than
signal
on the internet um and again this is
i'm not advocating for uh removing
everyone's twitter accounts but it's
definitely easier if the only people
that have voices are people that have
earned to have voices
then it means that you don't need to be
as discriminating with what you read
because you've the gatekeeping's already
been done yeah on the front end rather
than the back end yeah and and no you're
right it is and and this this is what's
leading to some of the polarization of
so many views and opinions on on online
those people who know enough about a
particular issue also probably know
where the weaknesses are in their
arguments also know what they don't know
and also they're probably less prepared
to get into a shouting point scoring
match and so they tend to retreat and
they just leave that forum for the two
extremes that are just lobbying missiles
at each other
um i mean one of them may be more right
than the other one of them
but but
it's led to this
you know black and white no room for
nuance no room for someone to say well
you know you got a point but you've also
got a point
you can't say that look if you're not
100 with me you're against me and and
the people who know about the subject
know that it's it's more complicated
than that and so because they're not
prepared to say i am 100 and once under
the other
they retreat and of course that's that's
the danger then you've left it just to
the extremes yes yeah there's a few so
many interesting things here one of them
being that um especially on the internet
any acceptance
of either a lack of understanding or a
lack of knowledge on your part which
would be i guess like intellectual
humility um or
a concession around somebody else's
point even if it's not all of it but a
little bit of it that's seen as a
uh
weakness from the opposing side and a
lack of commitment from the most extreme
people on your own side
yeah i mean it's something we've seen
all along in in politics for example you
know a politician will not admit
a mistake or not or they won't admit
that they were wrong about something uh
or very rarely anyway um and and it's
also so so far removed from the way we
do science you know in science admitting
your mistakes
is a strength
it's it shows that you are doing good
science that you're prepared to say well
i thought that
now i think this but you're right you
know in in in so many parts of wider
society that is seen as a weakness you
know when scientists have said
at the early days of the pandemic
uh in order to protect yourself from the
virus you just have to wash your hands
you know
i guess you you might know chris that in
the uk we the the mantra was wash your
hands while singing happy birthday twice
over oh i didn't hear that no thankfully
thankfully i was saved from that
atrocious
suggestion apparently that was the way
to tell the you know the the the stupid
public
that you need to spend a good few
seconds washing your hands thoroughly
sing happy birthday through twice and
that's enough
ridiculous notion but anyway a few
months later of course we discover that
the virus is mostly transmitted through
aerosols through the air
and then
what you you best do is make sure you're
in ventilated rooms open windows social
distancing masks and so on and a lot of
people said oh hang on a minute you told
us we just had to wash our hands and
we'd be protected now you're telling us
this you know nothing i don't believe
anything therefore you say
the problem is not understanding how
science works that science
can you know you can only base your
ideas and your views and your hypotheses
and theories on the evidence and
observations that you have available at
that time with more data coming in you
learn more
and that may mean
you have to change your mind it may mean
you are more confident on about your
hypothesis but it also may mean that you
were wrong
um getting that message across and and
maybe
exporting it to wider discourse in
society
i think would be a absolutely beneficial
for for it to be so if you if you're not
you're arguing with someone and say
actually no i think you've got a good
point there i think i was wrong about
that i i now understand where you're
coming from
for that not to be seen as a concession
as a weakness
would be wonderful but i mean that may
require changing human nature which is
yeah maybe it might be a bit much but
there's definitely some low resolution
thinking going on here yeah um and i do
think that it's in big part
due to people wanting uh simplistic
answers as a solution to a world which
is becoming ever more complex and
difficult to discern so you say science
unlike politics is not an ideology or
belief system it is a process but people
say
trust in science like they say trust in
god and then when you have something
that occurs like you know in the the
start of covid the
people in power really didn't make a
good showing of looking like competent
human beings and neither did some of the
researchers either so you go okay um
you don't know what you're talking about
but
the point is
at what point do you now accept that
that was maybe bound within one type of
issue maybe it was bound at that
particular time with how much
information they had maybe they don't
actually know maybe covid is a little
bit too complicated for them to actually
fully understand what's going on maybe
it's pandemics overall maybe it's the
entire scientific method and this is the
slippery slope where people kind of get
co-opted in with some like easy gateway
drug that you know they
they didn't know what they were talking
about to do with masks and before you
know it
some people with certain thought
patterns can be
flat earth lizard peopling around the
world and i i understand the compulsion
to do that and i'm just wondering about
how you put a a pattern interruption in
to stop
single or or um isolated cases of
scientific
negligence malfeasance ignorance
stupidity mistake whatever um cascading
down into something that's a bit more
serious
yeah i mean it was difficult with the
pandemic i guess because
everyone was so scared in the early days
and those scientists the epidemiologists
and uh and those who were you know
trying to sort of study and give advice
on how we should behave
uh
one can argue overreacted but that
overreaction was understandable given
how
frightening i mean what do you want to
do you want you want to under react like
in a world where you don't have all of
the information about a potential
world ending endemic do you want people
do you want the scientists to under
react this is something that no one
really ever says you're like look
maybe maybe being locked down in houses
was
an overreaction maybe the masking maybe
the social distancing maybe that you
can't see grandma and people dying in
hospitals and stuff like that and maybe
it was um held on for too long maybe it
was too conservative and the uh
prize should have been updated
but in the first instance
you say well
is it a is it totalitarian overreach
from a government that's trying to take
away your rights and prove
or is it just that the people in power
didn't know how bad it was going to be
and they didn't want people to die
and and and you know
there's a lot to be said for the
precautionary principle you know if you
are
not sure
about a particular course of action but
not doing it could potentially be
catastrophic then you better do it just
in case you know if your doctor tells
you
there's a there's a 60 chance that if
you don't give up smoking drinking or
change your diet you know you'll be dead
next year you don't think 60 percent
come on that's almost 50 50. you know
i'm not going to give up you know see
that's enough
you may be wrong there's a 40 chance
you're wrong but just in case i'm going
to do something so i think a
precautionary principle
means that
lower levels of confidence in in our
understanding
are allowed if the
the results the repercussions of not
doing anything are greater
and i think that's what what happened
with you know
the the similar sort of thing is is is
facing us with climate change that you
know we're not 100 sure that we humans
are destroying the planet
but the evidence is accumulating all the
time and
it's it's more the point that if we
don't do anything and we and and we're
right
then well we've
we've lost
uh so let's hope we're wrong but just in
case we do something about it so i think
it's inevitable that people will will
have come in hard with something as
unknown
uh in in terms of what it could do to to
humanity as the pandemic in the early
days what's the story about faster than
like neutrinos
right so
in in my book in the joy of science i
talk about the
how science can we as scientists we
could never be certain that something is
right we always have to say
there's a possibility that the sun won't
rise tomorrow or you know that our
particular understanding about something
is it isn't right and we've missed
something but with there are levels of
confidence there confidence there are
degrees of of of confidence that our
ideas and notions are right and you get
to the point where you say there's
certain things that are
you know we're we're very very sure
about
me 100 certain but never quite uh and
one of those i use this example from
physics that einstein tells us in his
special theory of relativity that um the
speed of light is the fastest possible
speed in our universe that is basically
woven into the fabric of space and time
it's not just a number that
einstein plucked out of the air why not
something a little bit faster
that is that's the maximum speed
possible in our universe and light
happens to be able to travel at that
maximum speed well
we're all confident about this um a
decade or so ago there was an experiment
where particles called neutrinos were
produced at cern in geneva
and these particles are very light they
are very weakly interacting with the
rest of matter that means that they can
travel through matter through the earth
itself as though the earth isn't there
because they're not bumping into
anything they don't do much bumping
and so the the beam of these neutrinos
was fired in a straight line from geneva
to this mountain in italy uh um where
there's a laboratory the grand sasso
laboratory uh under a mountain in italy
so because of the curvature of the earth
they're actually traveling slightly un
underground to
to follow a directly a straight line
the experimentalists who captured they
managed to capture a few of these
particles at the other end
and they measured because they knew the
distance precisely they knew the timing
of start and finish they calculated they
had got there by traveling slightly
faster than the speed of light
and uh you know that it's a press
release and and you know the world media
was excited they to their credit the
scientists said
tell us where we've gone wrong because
this is crazy you know but
most physicists including myself
didn't believe it we said no we are so
confident you know we're not certain
einstein could be wrong but we're so
confident that the speed of light cannot
be exceeded there must be something
wrong with these results
and you know what and you know some
people said oh see this is you know you
arrogant scientists you you think you
know it all and we say well look no no
we it will be great in fact if we can
fight if these nutritional vastness that
means our understanding of physics would
be wrong we have to rewrite the laws of
physics
chances are we we
it's it's wrong because so many other
experiments that confirmed the speed of
light being the maximum
they'd have to have been explained away
somehow
i
on twitter i said
if
i if the speed of light really is
exceeded by these neutrinos then i will
eat my boxer shorts live on tv
and forgetting that there are
journalists who follow me on twitter and
so before i knew it i found myself on on
bbc news one evening
where they interviewed me about about
this and i i had to repeat this thing
about box so i had to go through this
really embarrassing
you know pretending
i i knew it a day in advance
so i so i i had a spare pair of shorts
with me so i had this made made this
sort of act of you know sort of
and then pulling out my boxer and i
would eat my they said that would make
great telly so i believe them um and i
was getting you know recipes people
saying how to cook your boy you know
what dressing to put to uh if you cook
your box of shorts
anyway it turned out that i can't
remember how much later but the
experimentalists in italy realized they
there was a loose connection behind one
of the timing devices in in their
instrumentation and if that was clicked
into place properly suddenly the timing
between start and finish was different
and in fact these particles traveled
slower than the speed of light so
einstein lives to fight another day
so i just use this as an example that
you know extraordinary claims need
extraordinary evidence you can't dismiss
something like einstein's day of
just because
you know you've got an idea or because
you've carried out one test
there's a there's a lot has gone in to
try and knock einstein's theory of
relativity off its pedestal and we want
to we want to knock it down
because that means there's more
for us to discover
and yet it has survived and so gradually
because we've tried to disprove it
and we haven't been able to
we gain more and more trust in it and
that's when we talk about we have a
theory in science that we all trust
it could be einstein's theory it could
be darwinian evolution it could be plate
tectonics it could be the germ theory of
disease we are so confident that they're
right they might as well be facts that
doesn't mean we are certain it's just
highly unlikely that we're wrong
explain to me how
something can pass through the earth
like a neutrino
what what's happening there
well
mata is ultimately mostly empty space so
you know the earth is is
made of minerals and you know um various
compounds involving you know silicon and
oxygen and so on
ultimately down at the atomic scale
these are individual atoms and
individual atoms are a tiny nucleus
with electrons buzzing around the
outside but
most 99.99 of the volume of the atom is
just empty space
so when
i slam my hand down on my desk which you
can't see it's just out of shot but i'm
sure you can imagine
the reason it comes to a stop is not
because solid matter has hit solid
matter it's because the electrons in the
atoms on the surface of my hand
are feeling the electric repulsion
negative charge of the electrons in the
cer in the atoms in the surface of the
desk
and it's electromagnetic repulsion
that is giving matter this sense of
solidity that's why you can't walk
through brick walls
but if you turned off electromagnetism
then there's nothing to stop those
electrons from passing through and
that's what
neutrinos are doing they have no
electric charge
they are electrically neutral and so
they don't feel
the electromagnetic force
they feel what's called the the weak
nuclear force there are two forces that
operate inside atomic nuclei and that's
the only way neutrinos can interact with
matter of course there's also the force
of gravity but the neutrino is as near
as dammit massless it doesn't have any
mass at all so forget gravity pulling it
one way or the other so it travels
through the earth
zipping through the empty space through
all the atoms
and only if it were to
interact directly with say an electron
or within the the atomic nucleus will it
be stopped in its tracks which is highly
unlikely
that is wild that's so
wild talk to me we've mentioned about
about string theory uh and general
relativity at the moment
can you explain what the challenge is of
coming up with a grand unified theory at
the moment why
why can't we get things to fit together
yeah i mean usually in physics when we
talk about a grand unified theory we
tend to mean
a theory that still excludes gravity so
it's a theory that encompasses the other
three forces that we do have theories
for
uh the electromagnetic force and the two
nuclear forces
um you don't have one for gravity at the
moment we have a theory for gravity
which is einstein's general theory of
relativity
but it's a very different kind of
construct it's a theory about the
curvature of space-time it's not a
theory of
of sub-atomic particles bumping into
each other
or a theory of the quantum world
and so when we talk about ground unified
theory what we mean is one theory that
covers all the building blocks of matter
down at the the subatomic scale but
without the force of gravity when we
bring gravity in we start talking about
a theory of everything okay that's what
i meant what's the problem
so um
quantum mechanics has been tremendously
successful in
explaining the the microscopic world
uh uh you know we have now
quantum mechanics developed in the 1920s
then evolved into what we call quantum
field theory quantum field theory
explains all the interactions of matter
and light and and you know the the
building blocks of atoms
beautifully but gravity is the odd one
out and you know gravity on the cosmic
scale gravity is the is is the daddy you
know it's it's the most important
phenomenon it shapes the structure of
the entire universe
but you bring it down to the level of
atoms and gravity is much much weaker
you know two electrons will repel each
other because of their negative
charge
but they have masses so you might think
but don't do masses pull together
well they do but it's so tiny it's so
weak it's negligible
so we have einstein's general theory of
relativity which gives us the structure
of of the cosmos tells us about the big
bang about how the universe is expanding
uh the structure of galaxies and so on
uh it's this is our best theory of
gravity is our best theory of the nature
of space and time
but it's very different from the quantum
world and the theories described in the
quantum world so
we need to unify we want to unify the
theory of the small quantum mechanics
and the theory of the large general
relativity but because they're very
different structures we don't know how
to mesh them together and most
physicists working in this area
say well there must be a way of doing it
you know there's
we can think of examples in the physical
universe where both theories will apply
for example inside a black hole
um or just after the big bang
um
but we don't know how to bring them
together so that's sort of the holy
grail of physics to find a theory of
quantum gravity
string theory is one of the candidates
for such a theory
but
we don't know for sure if it's right
now the physicists working in string
theory will say yeah yeah it's pretty
much we're pretty sure it's right we're
just you know working through the maths
there are physicists who are working in
other on other potential candidate
theories who say now string theory is a
load of rubbish then there are other
physicists who who would argue that
too many bright people have devoted
their lives to string theory and all it
is is neat maths
uh it's it's uh it's very powerful maths
but
it's not
telling us something about the real
world that we live in and so stop
wasting your time guys and fund my
research because i want to do something
that's you know that's not string theory
so it's it's a bit of a you know what
camp you're in this it's almost like you
know ideological views as we know are
you for or against string theory yeah
i know it's it's interesting i had uh
michio kaku on the show last year and um
you know it it's interesting hearing
somebody that's dedicated so much time
to one particular type of theory uh
because
for all that scientists try and update
their priors and you know their bayesian
agents and all this stuff you do think
look man if you've dedicated
50 your career to one particular type of
theory
your ability to say do you know what it
is this isn't working guys we're up to
11 dimensions we're kind of wrapping the
theory around itself in order to be able
to make it fit something to do with the
what we're seeing in the real
is it possible
that the theory of the big and the
theory of the small simply don't
blend together or would that would that
be impossible do they have to be able to
mix
i used to think
that that was a possibility and maybe we
just have to live with
you know the the the the you know one
will incompatibility mutually because
they because they apply at different
scales entirely and therefore that never
the twain shall meet and we don't we
never have a scenario where we worry
but you can imagine
a situation where you have two electrons
you know that we can describe the
uh interaction between them using
quantum mechanics quantum field theory
but electrons have mass
and mass einstein's theorem relativity
tells us mass and energy
shape space-time
so space-time
will also be affected where those two
electrons are sitting
so
what happens
not only has to be described by
ultimately by uh
quantum mechanics but we also need to
just use general relativity to describe
the very tiny curvature of space-time
around those two electrons
it's a tiny tiny effect that's
negligible
but then
but that's a limit you know happening
it's happening there must be a theory
that that incorporates both as an
umbrella both general relativity and
quantum mechanics how wild is it that
there's something that so many people so
many smart people have dedicated so much
time and and resources to
and yet
you've kind of
not really got
anything that's that compelling you've
got uh plausible potentials
um and and not anything that people are
up in arms is yep there we go signed
sealed delivered yeah and a lot of
physicists you know until about
10 20 years ago a lot of his were very
um
confident that we that we were nearly
there you know whether they're working
super string theory m theory loop
quantum gravity you know they were quite
bullish about the fact that yeah you
know this is definitely the right way
it's very powerful we will get there but
it has stagnated over the last decade or
so
uh and and we haven't made the big
advances you know the the the last
really truly surprising advance in
physics was back in 1998 when we
discovered dark energy
you know the the stuff that we've done
in the 21st century confirming the higgs
boson uh
discovering gravitational waves well
they were both expected you know they
were both ticking a box confirming what
we suspected anyway so there weren't big
surprises so we are in a situation now
where the frustration is growing at the
large hadron collider they've not
discovered any more particles after the
higgs boson they were hoping to discover
a whole host of family of particles
called supersymmetric particles what are
they
well they would be particles that would
help
um explain what i was talking about
earlier about a grand unified theory
that unifies the electromagnetic force
the weak nuclear force and the strong
force
into one all-encompassing theory if you
want such a grand unified theory even
before gravity
then you s
one candidate is is that that theory has
to have this mathematical property
called supersymmetry
and if supersymmetry is a
a property of of our universe then that
means there are supersymmetric particles
that uh
they don't hang around very long they're
very unstable but given enough energy in
a lot in a particle accelerator you can
create them for you know fleetingly
and
we've we've thought we've had the
conditions to create them and and we've
not seen anything so that's a
frustration
dark matter we don't know what it's made
of yet we thought we'd have figured that
out by now but experiment after
experiment has found no ev
not no evidence because we know it's
there but no evidence of what dark
matter consists of there would have been
a nice explanation
which is that dark matter is made of a
type of supersymmetric particle
which would have been sort of super
convenient yeah very convenient but you
know in science it's not always the
convenient just because you want
something to be right or true doesn't
necessarily mean that's going to be so
who has got the most pressure on them at
the moment is it the theorists or the
experimentalists who needs to work their
game
theorists never have pressure fear is
just you know we'll come up with ideas
when i say we only because i'm a
theorist but i don't work on those sort
of foundational questions
and you know if if there's a suggestion
that it's wrong that some there's
something missing in the maths or then
experiment disprove it fine we move on
that was yesterday's theory
there are physicists working at the
foundations the very
borderline of what we know
who who very often don't even bother
publishing their papers in peer-reviewed
journals they'll write them as pre-print
so they stick them up online just as a
temporary measure for others in the
field to read them because they know in
six months from now they'll have moved
on to some other idea so unfortunately
it is the experimentalists who are
dealing with the real world not with
just you know pretty maths
who
sadly have to up their game because
after all physics ultimately is an
empirical science and it relies on
observations and evidence and data so
they've just we've just got to be clever
as experimentalists to design the
experiment that points us in the right
direction
what's the next big experiment that's
coming is there a super large hadron
collider is that happening there's still
talk there there that's still something
that's in the planning stages but you
know which countries will be involved
what it would actually look like where
it will be built is still something that
that is being discussed after the large
hadron collider took a couple of decades
to be built
and it hasn't you know we haven't
reached the end of what it can
may be able to deliver you know maybe
upgrading the large hadron collider will
be regarded as a much
cheaper way and and they'll be reluctant
from governments to to fund something
that's going to run into the many tens
of billions of dollars
if you know they look at the large
hadron collider and say well it
delivered the higgs boson which we sort
of knew was going to be there anyway
um how can you
you know promise us lots of new physics
with something much bigger
so what is it is there anything coming
up experimentally that's interesting any
new
i don't know telescopes or detection
well
i mean the the big the big excitement at
the moment there are there are certainly
new new um
terrestrial telescopes that are being
built but the big excitement the moment
is the james webb space telescope so
this is the the successors of the hubble
space telescope
so the change of telescope has has been
launched is it's it's you know going to
be providing us with information about
the universe
in far greater detail than we've ever
had before um it it might tell us
something about the structure of matter
about dark energy it might tell us
give us some hints as to whether there's
a signature of of life on on
exoplanets
um so a lot of certainly in in the world
of astronomy a lot of careers
are being built on what's going to come
from the james webb telescope in in
particle physics the other big science
in physics things aren't quite as rosy
because you know the large hadron
collider hasn't i guess lived up to its
promise and i'm sure there'll be
particle physicists who will hate me for
saying that but viewed from the outside
you know where the headlines are
that we haven't seen the new
breakthroughs and the discovery of new
particles that might have led to
breakthroughs
what area of research do you wish more
funding was put into what do you think
would be an interesting
uh area to have more funding given to
well i mean the area that's
exciting and fast-moving at the moment i
guess there is funding going into it is
is in in quantum
quantum technologies
developing
quantum
devices that rely on the weirder aspects
of quantum mechanics now
and i say weirder
quantum mechanics in the sense it's by
by weird i mean counter-intuitive and
more profound because of course you know
the fact that we're talking
recording this this podcast over skype
is thanks to quantum mechanics because
without quantum mechanics we wouldn't
have had any of modern electronics we
wouldn't have understood how to
the properties of super conductors and
chips and and and so on so the 20th
century
technologies everything from lasers to
the start of smartphones is all thanks
to quantum mechanics now in the 21st
century we're developing a new
generation of technologies
like quantum computers like quantum
cryptography and quantum teleportation
they're very sort of they're very clever
quantum sensors
that rely on these strange ideas and
quantum mechanics of two particles being
separated and yet entangled with each
other so that one
the fate of one this
affects the other and so on
uh and so i think this is an area that
is rapidly developing
more funding should go into it but i
guess
you know it will be driven by
once a science has a
an application in the marketplace
then you know capitalism comes down
to takes over yeah exactly exactly did i
see that um
quantum computers had managed to do two
plus two equals four
yes amazing isn't it so they've
confirmed that
i mean ibm and google uh and the big the
big guys are
making
impressive progress in in continuing
are still away yet from having a a
desktop quantum computer
but you know um
they are starting to get you know
incrementally
more and more good at what quantum
computers do
and what computer content is they're not
going to replace our
everyday computers or super computers
they'll but there'll be certain tasks
that they can do
much much more quickly than the most
powerful computers we have any idea what
they would be useful for
well um things like um sifting through
lists sifting through data
um
solving prob certain problems in in in
mathematics i mean but people argue that
a quantum computer will be able to
decipher encrypted
codes you know out what the public key
access the reason why it's safe to put
your credit card details online
essentially relies on
the fact that multiplying two large
numbers together
is much easier than breaking up
their answer into the two numbers that
you had to myself prime factors of of
large numbers
quantum computers will be able to crack
that much more quickly than uh fantastic
so quantum computers can brute force
their way into my email account yeah but
but luckily in line with that we will
also be developing new techniques of
encryption using quantum mechanics as
well it's an arms race so it's an arms
race between quantum encryption and
quantum you know um
um
key cracking code cracking um but uh
yeah i think
there are lots of
in in science that there's the hope that
quantum computers can help
us understand certain structures in
physics and chemistry for example
you know down at the quantum atomic
scale
the world it behaves quantum
mechanically
and we to understand it we try to we
create simulations
uh models on our computers well it's far
better to create a quantum simulation of
a quantum process using a quantum
computer
then
not a not really a quantum simulation
using a non-quantum computer so you know
lots of chemists and nuclear physicists
and condensed metaphysis would be very
keen to use quantum computers to study
matter down at the quantum scale do you
think that the mission to mars
to try and live and set up a base on
mars is a good use of time and resources
that's a difficult one i think um
i think there's still a lot more
mileage in sending
non-human missions to to mars and the
other planets you know our
uh development of robotics and ai
which is another fantastically exciting
area science technology is developing so
quickly
that
i don't think i mean very soon it's
going to be very hard to justify sending
humans to mars
uh the added expense
if i worked in that area i'd be arguing
passionately that you need humans on the
ground to be digging um but
dispassionately standing away from it i
could imagine many you know we could
fund many more projects to mars and the
moons of
saturn and jupiter
uh
without human intervention
then
far fewer
projects where we're sending people to
those planets so it'll come i mean no
it's not you know we're not going to be
stuck on earth forever provided we don't
wipe ourselves out and we solve climate
change and we don't start a nuclear war
with russia
and all that business
there will come a day when of course
we're going to be
you know populating
the solar system and beyond but at the
moment i think there's more mileage in
terms of the limited scientific uh
research funding that we have
to send unmanned spacecrafts to the out
to the solar system that's an
interesting way to look at it uh if we
dance through the minefield that is
existential risk appropriately and we
miss
artificial misaligned artificial general
intelligence and we evade engineered
pandemics and so on and so forth
um
one of the problems is that you kind of
have another arms race going on a
literal race between the amount of
x-risk that you are prepared to deal
with uh at home on earth
and the number of other options that we
have outside of that right and slowing
down the speed of technology production
the um urn of potential black balls that
nick bostrom talks about each time that
you create a technology it could be
white good could be grey kind of good
kind of bad or it could be black which
is totally terrifying and can kill us
all um
that means that there is
a degree of urgency um because
we can't take a god's eye perspective
and just slow down which would be my if
we had the option i would say look let's
just slow technology down by
a hundred times
and let's go super incremental with
everything that we do because if you
take us a very very very long
civilizational time frame with this you
think well what's the rush the only rush
for us to get somewhere else is to
counter the risk that we're creating
because we can't have um global
coordination around the development of
technology it's like i want i want every
single line of computer code to be
tested for whether or not it's malicious
step by step by saying yeah yeah
in in an ideal world of course i mean i
think it's that sort of happened in
things like in in areas like genetics
you know where
scientists in most countries not
everywhere have you know
taken out a moratorium on on on gene
editing germline editing and so on you
know
where
it in
ideally it could be a wonderfully
powerful tool where you could go in and
and snip away mutations and and and uh
you know combat um
genetic diseases
um but of course in the wrong hands it
can lead to all sorts of horrific
scenarios
um so yeah i think so a lot of
scientists are saying hang on a minute
step back let's think about this let's
examine the ethical and moral
implications of what we're doing
but it's not it won't happen everywhere
and and it's not happening in other
areas you know the uh
artificial intelligence is is another
example we're not slowing down
the the pace of development in robotics
and automation and machine learning so
on it's happening and coming at us very
quickly we're not you know it's not like
terminator terminator and skynet are
just around the corner
but
we don't seem to be able or the powers
that be have no appetite for slowing
down that technology so the best we can
do
is
get talking about it get that
conversation going and and try and keep
the ethical and moral debates about what
we should and shouldn't do
in in the same race
with with the technology if we can't
slow the technology down we better speed
up our conversations yeah i like that
the uh i wonder whether or not the
intention is going to be to air gap mars
from earth but that seems like a
complete waste as well you go look like
what are we what are we going to mars
for are we going to mars
because we want to have a
second cradle of humanity in which we
are protected from any of the potential
concerns and but then if one of those
and one of the big four runners you know
it's whatever one in six chance over the
next hundred years that ai is going to
destroy civilization based on uh
toby od's book
if that's the case if that's one of the
real real reasons that we're going then
you you need to be air-gapped
from the earth you need to be able to
have nothing be sent to mars no signals
no communication or not and you go okay
but we're also there to do research to
be able to improve our quality of life
here on earth so you you can't have both
so what we may need to do is there's
gonna have to be a trade-off made here
look what do you want you want to be
able to go to another planet and use it
for research and for sending back
information and for scientific testing
and stuff like that
or do you want it as the
ejector seat emergency backup system
for civilization because i i don't think
that you can do both
we we're not
looking that far ahead
to see mars as that ejector see the the
escape route if things go to pot here on
earth
we are
sort of making
taking the calculated risk that
we will resolve and solve the problems
here on earth and that we are not going
to design a virus that's going to kill
everyone we're not going to
mutually nuclear destroy the world
um we're not going to be hit by
a meteorite
um
and i think it's it's
you know climate people say well you're
going to go to mars because you know
we're destroying
the earth's climate well
however bad climate change
affects our planet
it's still
many orders of magnitude
more preferable than the environment on
mars you know when we're when we're not
talking about terraforming mars at the
moment we're not talking about seeding
it giving it its atmosphere back again
and so on so you know it's still a long
way from being a place where
any more than just you know a handful of
researchers who are well trained go over
there to do research it's not somewhere
where we can go and live it's so far in
the future
that you know we're not prepared to put
in that sort of we we didn't even put
money into sort of pandemic preparedness
eve despite so many people saying pandem
a pandemic could come at any moment guys
and yeah yeah yeah you know and
sure enough
it did and no one's got any ppe or uh
toilet roll a couple of weeks in yeah
and that and that was a real you know a
real possibility so so i mean i think
with with mars and and using that escape
is so far in the future that people just
aren't it's not on the horizon at the
moment yeah you're right i would way
sooner take a hot earth over a um cold
mars you know indeed
one of one of the best quotes that
you've got in your new book is that you
won't reach a clearer understanding of
what's going on by valuing opinion over
evidence one of the problems that we
have is when there's so many conflicting
claims about what the evidence is and
what it says
that's very difficult to work out and i
also think another element of this is
which has been facilitated by the cult
of personality
social media is
increasingly we we
we follow people not ideas now so um
elon musk 80 million twitter followers
like uh
spacex
four million twitter followers cristiano
ronaldo 40 million instagram followers
real madrid eight million right we we
follow people we don't follow things
right or ideas um and when you
not going to value opinion over evidence
and there's way too much conflict around
what that evidence is or what the
opinions are and then because we have
this sort of natural seduction for
people all of that mixed together i
think
it just creates a very difficult
landscape for people to do sense making
in
yeah again i mean this is
in a sense i mean apart from it the size
of the problem it's not a new one you
know we've always had
profits and and and uh cassandra
cassandra's yes we've had you know the
the those who will lead those who will
be listened to those who have the
the the you know the the
strength of personality that is going to
attract followers
um it's just that the internet and
social media has
allowed anyone to to to try their luck
at this and and of course there's going
to be those who for whatever reason
you know whether because they're
multi-billionaires or because they're um
they're great at sport
or simply because they got lucky and and
for for whatever reason you know you
look some of the the influences on on
instagram i think
what is it what where's your talent
where you know how come people are
listening to you and there it doesn't
seem to it just it has happened um
i don't think we've yet
come to terms with how to deal with how
social media in particular has amplified
what are problems that have always
existed in humanity the same with things
like conspiracy theories and the same
with um things like ideological you know
in the past you know
generation or two ago you got your views
from a newspaper that you read
uh and that and and because it aligned
with your political opinions for example
and and that was fine and we all had we
all lived in our confirmation bias echo
chambers it was fine
the internet and social media
haven't created a new problem they've
just amplified a problem that is part of
human nature and we haven't yet figured
out you know maybe that we we restrict
the voices to those
that we as a society decide know what
they're talking about
um but we haven't figured out the right
way of doing that that that people can
agree on that seems to be fair yeah well
i was thinking as you were talking
earlier about
a new type of verification system you
know you've got your blue ticks but
maybe maybe a grey tick or a
yellow tick means that this person has
reached a particular
level of
a number of citations
on their work within their specific
field or whatever because it is becoming
increasingly effortful and there's there
is no solution to this to just
cut through the noise and find a little
bit of signal
and what you get after a while and i see
this in myself
i just kind of check out of discussions
sort of apathy sets in so i go well
i don't know if i can't work out what's
right and or what's wrong and if any
time that i try to find it out i'm told
that i'm a a conservative or a shill or
a great you know
whatever word you want sheeple grifter
whatever like in that case i'm not going
to engage
and that's even worse
you know people simply not engaging
because it's either too effortful or
daunting for them to go ahead and do it
yeah i mean but but if you know it's not
going to lead to anything if you know
neither there's not going to be any
compromise and at least when you're you
know in in a bar with friends or
whatever you you when you're face to
face and you you probably you know you
you're
you're not going you're going to see
them again you know your paths are going
to cross in the future you tend to reach
some sort of a compromise very often you
know it might things might get into a
chatty match but on social media because
every everyone is invisible from
everyone else and and it's so
instantaneous and you don't have to
think about what
and you know you can put a really good
argument against something but what
comes back is you know they've ignored
that and and they've they've taken a
different direction but just as strident
so it is soul destroying and and and
a bit of i tend not to there are there
are certain debates that i won't get
into at all i mean
the transgender debate
absolutely polarizing society
mainly a generational issue
but but no one is allowed to say
trans rights are important but i can
understand why some women feel
uncomfortable
to say that
the the
you know one side will say you're
transphobic the other side will say you
know you're you're anti-feminist
misogynist
and so there's no nuance in in many
debates on social media and so you're
right you know it's not just if you are
arguing from one side and not realizing
not getting anywhere with the opposing
view
it's also if you if you realize that
actually this issue is more complicated
than either side would admit because
they've narrowed it down to memes and
tweets
and no one wants to listen to
nuance
then you also
pull yourself away and say well okay
there's no point i if if i'm in the
middle both sides are going to attack me
so might as well say nothing yeah being
out on the extremes
uh guarantees you agreement from at
least one but being in the middle
guarantees disagreement from both from
both exactly and and and and most issues
are more complicated than we'd like
like to think uh and as as we discussed
earlier the experts the people who know
about the about this particular issue
know about the subtleties know about the
nuance
uh and therefore inevitably will find
themselves somewhere
in the middle ground not i'm not saying
in the middle you know if you're if it's
an argument between
you know a nasty person and a nice
person someone who's tolerant with
someone who's a bigot then then clearly
the in between the right place to me is
very much closer to the tolerant person
right
but nevertheless you know those are the
people though people who know are the
will will inevitably step step away from
these debates
jim alkali ladies and gentlemen if
people want to check out your stuff
online where should they go
i have a website gmalkali.com without
the hyphen um oh actually no it does
have a hyphen
tell people the wrong address um
where i you know you can find out about
my books my i'm still an active
researcher working at the university of
surrey in england and
you know teaching students but i also do
a lot of science communication so some
of the stuff you can find on my website
jim i appreciate you thanks for today my
pleasure chris thank you what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace